never before had the flames come this
close
forcing everyone in this village in
northern portugal to leave their homes
and as the blaze closed in residents
battled to contain it alongside
firefighters
this is just one area of southern europe
gripped by a heat wave which has sent
temperatures soaring to dangerous levels
in france more than 12 000 people had to
evacuate as the inferno raised homes and
businesses in its path
in a calm down this morning and
apparently it started again
and now we're being asked to evacuate
urgently
yes i'm worried this is my house
firefighters are battling to contain
wildfires in the bordeaux region that
have already burned almost 10 000 acres
we are on the edge of this area where
you have pine trees which are full of
resin at their base
this burns to their core and they end up
falling this is an additional danger for
the firefighters and as you can see on
this path they will block the progress
of the rescue services
and over the border in spain 17 forest
fires still rage across the country
with some getting dangerously close to
towns in the sierra miha mountains
the heat that spanned their flames has
already caused over 300 deaths according
to spanish authorities
and as the high temperatures and dry
conditions continue
we may yet see more fires leaving
scorched earth in their wake
milana vasilinovic sky news